leuchtet jetzt kommt der absolute war
die härteste sache die meine schwester
schon immer gehasst habe ich bis zum
ende auf warten natürlich das war
handelt es sich um nichts geringeres als
service heute herzen kommen zu einem
neuen video es ist wieder sei es wird
essen getestet heute mit der wahrheit
stellvertretender essens tester waren
wir da mein name ist krankhafter ich bin
der stellvertretende experte geht es auf
mein name ist auch mag
ich war länger nicht mehr im kanal zu
sehen jeffrey miasto stadt mit
und heute leute geht es darum wie rapp
zum titel schon gesehen dass wir essen
testen was unsere kleine schwester schon
immer gehasst hat eine ganz kurze sache
vorneweg leute
falls ihr euch fragt wo meine kleine
schwester jetzt gerade ist die sache ist
die also ich bin ja ihr großer bruder
als großer bruder will ich natürlich auf
sie aufpassen und sie wirklich
beschützen und deswegen will ich weil
sie erst 14 ist sie noch nicht im
internet zeigen einfach weil ich weiß
wie viele menschen ist der gipfel
ich will einfach meine kleine schwester
sind in die gefahr bringen das irgendwie
fertig gemacht wird deswegen jetzt im
heutigen video nicht dabei aber sie hat
uns gesagt was ich schon immer gehasst
hat ich hab's eingekauft und ich will so
einen will starten mit der ersten sein
die sache ist ich hab ein bisschen angst
weil unsere schwester ist eigentlich
ähnlich drauf wie sebastian sylvester
ist eigentlich der übelste allesfresser
ramos wenn da jetzt was dabei nicht
schmeckt dann bin ich mit ziemlich
großer wahrscheinlichkeit so was raus
aber gucken wir mal was es ist also ich
kann nicht mal so viel weg sagen leute
wenn ihr euch das letzte video mit sonny
arena die sachen die wir heute haben
sind deutlich besser und leckere und
umso seltsamer ist es dass man schwester
sie gehasst hat aber van sache
nummer-eins-hits gross selbst
veranlassen leiter von ok wo fangen wir
also was gesehen
ich glaube ja und wenn es das ist was
ich denke was das ist dann wäre dies
nicht die frage an und das gleich ist
und zwar die erste
wenn ich meiner schwester absolut
gehasst hat immer noch hass sind reife
banane der ich muss kurz klären
verraten wird grünheid der hand und sagt
ich bin dann gleich in der sache ohne
witz ich hab das glaube ich in meinem
essen testen video schon gegessen und
ich finde es klappt also macht das auch
an anderen hat er gemacht kann sehen
dass wir das noch mal essen und sich
meine wahren weg ist nicht reif der
eisenbahn sind der inbegriff der welt
der pokémon fragen wir an wir haben hier
zwei reife bananen ich habe natürlich
extra für dich eine besonders schöne
lieder ausgesucht weil ich erst dass
nicht er ist ja jetzt das militär sind
auf eine weise findet anders klappt sie
sind nicht machen darf noch mal gucken
männern eine einzige brauner fleck ist
in der mitte ein einziger baum effekt
und ist dann ruhig ruhig das nicht
angegangen
okay das war mal eine chance auf das
ticket berechtigt titel hoch verdichtet
ich hab jetzt gegen den geruch von
bananen ich finde diese glitschige basta
konsistenz mindestens genauso schlimm
wie diese braunen flecken kann man jetzt
ein roter fleck wird sie noch essen
würdest du hier und jetzt kein brauner
bist du behindert hast du da oben drauf
geschaut bisher nicht brauchen was ist
es dann ist das weiße trikot ist die
spitze der banane braun oder weiß er was
ich jetzt sage noch mal eine banane und
dessen telefonnummer vertan es nicht
bleiben
okay wir diesmal wieder anfang an ein
großer bruder bestimmt sich natürlich
immer eine kleine schwester sondern auch
dich und fange an
also muss er trotzdem rein weißen danach
aber ich war doch mal ganz klein ist
weil da oben scheint einigermaßen kitzen
halt dein maul ist läge dieses liegt uns
geschäfte hölle auf das brettchen
wüstenrot die banane operiere legt das
geschäft der hölle auch das recht habe
ich gesagt hatte schon einen so hängen
die menschen gesehen
was ist so ein widerlicher geschmack
eltern dieses glück bringe das ist so
ekelhaft ich hasse banane sicher die
meisten sachen die man mal so gegessen
hat mag man der land wieder nennt die
als kind nicht mochte banane in schale
hast du dich ich hab zwar noch einmal
angeboten
ich habe alles versucht hast du sagst
ich habe tatsächlich kein problem mit
dem geschmack von banane also so
milchshake in den bann
es kann krieg runter mag ich jetzt nicht
so wahnsinnig gerne aber diese
konsistenz die pokémon ganz kurz ich
lasse hier zwar abstimmen was du bock
auf etwas herzhaftes jetzt gerade ganz
alleine essen dort schon gesehen was es
herzhafte ist sicher wenn es das ist was
gesehen hat dann würde das mit
sahnetorte die nächste sache wird euch
umhauen glaube ich glaube das lasse sich
nicht viele finden die das aufpassen
denn meine kleine schwester hast alles 2
am heutigen tage ihre täter bounty ich
dachte das wäre das andere das hier
später wie kann man die hassen jakob
kurze meinung nach einen kurzen exkurs
man kann durchaus gute gründe haben die
meisten bauten wie das englische wort
gekommen wären wenn ein kopfgeld
ausgesetzt sein kann das durchaus
verstehen dass die leute es mögen kopf
der gruppe aus dem westen stehe ich habe
demnächst geben
manchmal klingt okay kommt will man
jetzt keinen großen fast jeder weitere
frau sie ist aber sind mit kokosnuss
achten stock tun nicht so als würdest du
das immer normale du kleine misst alle
debatten ist nämlich sein bounty indem
er so alle seiten ab nach und was im
leben so frei legt um 8,8 das ist
sowieso eine fiese alien spezies diese
auf die erde gekommen ist und so selbst
erarbeiten musste wie man sachen ist
deshalb ist die nicht wie normale
menschen aber die ist schade aber ich
weiß was ich an die knapp was flossen
ja okay was zu sagen ist ein hammer geil
fett oder also jetzt nicht absichtlich
werden gebaut habe ich schon habe so
gefallen das war für mich als kind aber
ist im besten sich könnte es also mal du
warst weise snickers mars menschen oder
wasser sogar etwas übrig noch dadurch
etwas wirklich will wird bester bislang
unter den top-fünf moment meines lebens
wir sind umgezogen als ich glaube ich so
zehn oder elf war
da waren wir so im neuen haus und das
war noch nichts da und ich hab so ein
wetter nicht gestillt und hatte so einen
packendsten nicht also zehn snickers und
hatte harry potter buch noch nicht
gelesen hatte danach ich mir diese zehn
sneaker so andere teil geballert und
auch so viele sportler gewesen
die beste zeit meines lebens an der
stelle kann man nur sagen
tabea zweiten keinen spaß sagt was ich
mit dir ja kommt man schon mal das
schmeckt gut
solche ist hart für den am ende machen
macht sinn oder was am ende dann kommen
wir als nächstes zu einer sache die auch
jeder normale mensch feiern würde aber
dieser fakt obst hasse wahrscheinlich
wieder gar nicht mag mancher leute
manchmal mag vielleicht weiß rein wenn
du gehst rein gewaschen und in der
emigration gekürzt sagte bruder
die gestörte polizisten festgehalten
[Musik]
da fragte vorher landes überwiegen
rausgesprungen
berlin
ich weiß macht ein bisschen scheiße mit
lebensmitteln aber es erst 2019
was soll da das wasser wird meistens
nicht werktags die bahn oder bus handelt
es wird alles gegessen ok muss sich im
banat oft bleibt für immer ein teil der
s kids für immer nächste sache der graf
auch raus die probst und gemüsebereich
bei so einem erstmal gucken okay kann
ich jemand weiter brand mit ja und genau
die nächste sache leute ist schon wieder
ein bisschen ich gelacht da könnte man
sagen ich meine die hat auch schon mal
jemand mitgebracht die fitte sagte die
schwester schon immer gehasst hat und
immer noch hass ist beim mittelrhein für
mich das habe nichts mit essen testen
kein mensch nimmt diesen dingen und
meister ryan wahnsinniger nein lass das
hat nichts mehr zu essen zu tun wir
schneiden einsteiger davon abhält liegen
aber niemand nimmt so eine knolle und
ist das so
der wenn er es einfach so ist alles was
du dann in einem unter also so schlecht
ist wie findest du immer ganz gut ich
hab noch nirgendwo gegessen
ja als 80 scharf aber es galt meine
meinung
was ist das schon wieder von bord was
soll es sein tag heißen berichtet ein
vertrauter was also ist nicht an bord
auch tapfer kann die kleine menge
immerhin so geht das doch immer und du
bist doch ein spaßiger geschäft die erst
beantwortet man muss auch sagen leute
kennt ist eigentlich so irgendwann das
ist aber so konnte die extremform ist es
zwar normalerweise kommt man nach dem
essen war nur in ruhe ist hat man den
reinsten geschmack und die
meisterschärpe und selbst so geht's klar
für mich projekte festhalten haltet euch
fest leute jetzt kommt der absolute
burner die härteste sache die man ich
weiß da schnell mal mehr hast dann habe
ich bis zum ende auf warten natürlich
macht ist bereit dafür würde außer von
essen auf jeden fall eine schöne und das
war handelt es sich um nichts geringeres
als
du bist du dumm also wer sich jemals
andere mit übrigens heute der wahl
rauskommt auch mit örtlichen trage einen
rollmops einmal mit dem bild vor der die
unikate sagt damit machen
ja ich ganz gut
mit links mit rechts ich kann natürlich
so minister sagen warum wir machen jetzt
steht ja auch du glaubst doch nicht dass
ich damit irgendetwas zu tun habe
ja das ist richtig es geht anders
versichert er ich kann man das leider
nicht auf sondern ist als hättest du
wirklich sehr gerne hast du das mal
gesehen die wahnsinnige die vor kurzem
mehr wer kann das gut verstehen dass du
das nicht essen willst also ich muss
sagen es ist nicht das ich würde es mir
jetzt nicht von haus aus holen
aber natürlich könnte diese serie nicht
immer ein kanal machen wenn ich nicht
zertifizierte allesfresser wäre und
dementsprechend wird hier meine nein
soll ich gut gesehen ja aber wir immer
schlimmer machen was wird nicht aber
leute es ist meine aufgabe ist jetzt
rein als job verloren dass kein mensch
mehr
das ist aller lecker ist würde ich würde
mir nicht wie gesagt nicht selbst ins
haus holen aber man kann sich gehen darf
ist weiter von diesem video der praxis
runden in der beschreibung von den
vielen dank auch an meiner schwester
da werde durch die beste das mir die
vorschläge für dieses video gemacht hast
ihr könnt ihr ihn für euch persönlich
vorgeschlagen das video abchecken wir
sind raus max ist tot